did you know this was a success did you
expect empire to be what it was like you
know those tv
tv shows that are really hit shows they
don't come often you don't get the ones
that reach the global status
often you guys reached global status
that was a
monumental
hit so for you in the beginning stages
did you know that realize that when you
know you guys are pilot in first season
i knew it would be hit domestically
okay i wasn't expecting international
okay because i was told my entire career
that black don't do well overseas
then i get overseas to paris of all
places
and 1500 seats standing room only
french speaking citizens
they hid me in the audience it was a q a
lee's on the stage and when they got to
the cookie questions he said well
let's ask her here she is listen to me
the entire room stood to their feet
and
like this i stood on that stage and ugly
face cried in front of those people
because
they lied to me yeah
then when i go outside
they weren't greeting me as cookie
please be saying
but they had jackets to all my movies
baby boy included even movies that hit
um the one we did not easily broken this
parisian came out and was like these
three things like i said what you how
you doing this didn't even go to many
theaters but he had it there they had it
in china when i went it's like so
somebody's been lying to me that's why i
applaud you and i look up to you because
you didn't listen you said i'm doing
myself
and you went abroad you took your show
abroad and that's what it takes it takes
um for us especially
um this has always been our struggle
we're always fighting against everything
you know trying to rise above that thumb
that constantly stays on us you know and
i just applaud you for that
i'm just so proud of you i know you i'm
here to talk to you but i'm you i'm so
i've been proud of you
you know and i feel like
i mean i just watched the whole thing i
just never forget we were on a plane
going somewhere people don't understand
how how we're connected though yeah
right they and they're not supposed to
no no no they don't know the connective
tissue between you and i but to give you
a little background on it you know not
easily broken
that was a big deal for me me too that
was
i i know it was a big deal for you but
i'm saying at that point in my career
i needed substance i needed i needed
movies that were quote unquote credible
i needed credible actors and actresses
that i could stand alongside and i
remember me and morris you know me and
morris were cool
and he approached me about a project
when i first met clint culpepper he was
like taraji man it's gonna be me and
taraji it's a big one and i remember i
remember my mindset about taraji oh my
god this is dope taraji's
she's about it's it's there and morris
was that guy and i'm like this is great
and that movie for me
it it acted as
a big stamp for me mentally
yeah i'm doing the right thing think
like a man to me was it like i was like
look at us
i was just i sat back and was like look
at us you can't write a better you can't
write a better story but the first one
you were still like on that still coming
up coming up and then the second one
they was like um kevin gonna get paid
more than anybody
i was like
[Music]
you